[Music]
hey what's up all right he was doing
that like well I'm already intro was
going you just started drinking don't
get all excited no when I swallowed it
was like
no now poopy's looking at you like what
the hell's wrong no it's okay we're not
mad we're not mad she's like is somebody
mad at me did I do something no we're
just getting ready to [ __ ] start the
show it's all right Pookie you're fine
uh today uh we're gonna it's uh another
haunting Mondays yes it is talk about
paranormal cases of The Haunting series
because there's so many of them and you
guys are [ __ ] great fans of them in
many seasons these are I think I have a
total of nine Seasons these are fun to
do well we have we have this first seven
seasons in physical medium and then you
we bought the eighth season yeah the
eighth season there's like four seasons
there but yeah you can't yeah you can't
get it on on DVD though
so past season eight past season seven
or well past season seven I think that
was the last one they did like on DVD
like in physical media and then they
just went online
so we bought season eight but there's
one like what's there one season that we
couldn't buy yeah it wasn't for sale it
was there but they said it's not not
available not available for whatever
reason I don't know must be probably
like there's a couple of them like that
yeah but it's like we'll eventually I
don't even think we've watched all of
season eight yet no and I think I think
there might be like 11 or 12 Seasons
there's there I think there's more than
that actually they might have gone up to
12 or 13 maybe but this one uh was Tom
Sykes recommendation yeah which is a
change because usually Danny rolling uh
Danny rolling Ghostface uh recommends
them because he's like a super fan but
this one was a Tom Sykes recommendation
and this was actually a good one this
was season seven
episode 9 nightmare in the attic and
it's weird because we remember this one
but it's good yeah we have season seven
like we have like a multi-pack like DVD
of all of them and we watched them at
some point but I barely remembered this
one but this was actually like a decent
episode it wasn't as silly as I thought
it was going to be like from the intro
you start getting into season seven and
because you're so familiar with this
series they all kind of start to feel
the same
and you get confused and like I said the
titles are easily forgettable because
they're all basically the same yeah
something or other horror that Horror in
the basement
attic up in your booty just weird [ __ ]
like that you never [ __ ] know evil
from the grave evil from the grave
[ __ ] you know the Shadow from within
I just made that [ __ ] up
there might be one call about that the
evil spirit
from without
[Laughter]
that's gas
but uh
the demon on the roof yeah so when we
were watching this and I was like I
recognized the people the witnesses
and um
it was a it was it's a fun episode it's
a fun case I don't know if it really
happened but we're gonna get into it um
it's
I don't think it's Poltergeist it would
be haunting I think I mean possibly
something like Poltergeist but yeah they
were first going in a haunting Direction
and then it kind of went a little more
demonic they weren't like super I liked
that this one didn't have an exorcism or
a cleansing or anything like that
because that kind of gets a little samey
after a while too this one they
basically just brought in a relative
that was kind of like a psychic and
she's like yeah this place is [ __ ] up
you need to get the hell out of here and
like so much bad [ __ ] had happened that
they were like okay so they just did
right you know what I mean so they
didn't really have a lot of church
involvement in this one which is
interesting because
I found out later they did mention this
on the show
but that
um the the guy that was on there that
was like a son he was like a kid when
this stuff happened uh he was eight
uh he became a Paranormal Investigator
later on which is something that
happened on a few of the other
um you know uh episodes that we talked
about and he has written a couple of
books like I found three books that he'd
written one of them interestingly uh was
available to read on Kindle unlimited
which I have so I'd kind of like
scrolled through it but I didn't like
want to read the whole thing because uh
it wasn't about this case he did write a
book about this case
fairly recently like in 2018 but he
wrote One in 2015 about another family
that was also featured on a haunting
that was the episode that I think was
also from season seven that was called
Child's Play nothing to do with Chucky
now some people might discount this and
go well they're involved in this as a
business so of course they're gonna man
I don't look at it that way I saw a
poltergeist Jenny wrote about it and
then she started I'm on the back of that
one she started writing about other
cases through Steve Mara a
parapsychologist yeah I like about his
cases and then she wrote an unseen hand
i'm plugging the books right now Jenny
yes I see I see that through an unseen
hand which is like one of the best
biggest collections of poltergeist cases
throughout history uh but Steve said man
this is like a reference book okay this
is this well that's kind of why because
there wasn't really one like that right
I felt like so um
but he added that to his library of
[ __ ] cases to go to so anyway
um just because uh you end up writing
something about it later that doesn't
disqualify you yeah that doesn't
necessarily mean that it's because uh
the [ __ ] I saw [ __ ] and me and my
family saw was real I mean just because
the Amityville Horror was [ __ ]
that's right it doesn't mean
I mean I got pictures from back in the
80s of us taking you know chairs upside
down and [ __ ] towels rearranged why
the [ __ ] would I get in a time machine
and go back to the 80s and take pictures
of towels
yeah you know what I mean especially
using Polaroid films which is not cheap
yeah no it's because we didn't know what
else to do and there was only like eight
or 12 of them in the little packet you
know what I mean so you couldn't waste
that that was all we had we didn't have
very many photos and every time it moves
something we go take a picture of that
we take a picture you know to somebody
who wouldn't if somebody didn't have any
contacts to go why the [ __ ] are you
doing why are you arranging are you
wasting your Polaroid film on taking a
picture of a bunch of times why are you
taking pictures of a damn rocking chair
upside down
you know yeah there's a reason for it
yeah that's how we found it you know
okay so
I'm not going to Discount the case
I've never seen a case quite like this
in person you know it was like a demonic
haunting according to Steve
he says these cases exist that he's seen
weaker ones but that they're out there
it's kind of like a mixture of Haunting
and Poltergeist
or a ghost that has the ability to move
objects basically
and sometimes throw people around
me I associate that with rspk
Poltergeist all right but he says there
are some cases that are kind of in
between and I'd probably put that this
case in that kind of an in between yeah
this one seemed a little bit weird like
it had like a lot of kind of something
for everybody yeah if it happened it's
something in between I don't discount it
you had some elements of rspk or
Poltergeist you had a kid who was about
eight in the house and you have a girl
that's about 17. so there might be a
chance of there being one of the two
being a poltergeist Focus
and it was a bigger family
there was some turmoil in the family so
it may be Poltergeist but it
if the story is if it happened the way
the story is told
it would be
Steve would call it demonic haunting I
think and I'll note that the house I
mean if like I said we're just operating
on the Assumption and everything they're
saying is true
um then uh the uh there were rumors
about the house before they got there
yeah because they were just renting it
you know what I mean so the house was a
bad place which I've been in bad houses
before
every bad house I was in was mostly one
bad house that sticks into mine nothing
ever moved it was just a bad house
everybody could feel it
you know even people that didn't even
know that didn't even know that it was a
bad house to go ooh but he looked
totally normal it just felt like he
would be a watch to wherever you went
like an unnatural Stillness had bad
dreams in there and [ __ ] the psychic
attack kind of what happened in here
yeah psychic attacks for something you
feel like something visible just trying
to get up into the back of your [ __ ]
neck and get inside your skull and you
can't you don't know what it is it's
just some kind of invisible attacker
and then you're like man then it passes
you're like man am I car am I crazy or
did that happen but I had I'd already
seen Poltergeist I was like no that
happened
and my Army buddy was with me you know
[ __ ] uh Eric and he weird [ __ ] like
that was happening to him too
that he felt like somebody was watching
him you get some ice Tom's sake says too
bad the old pair of shoes didn't do a
jig or do the moonwalk
I mean we kind of like you know we'll
kind of like get into that but it's like
um you know we laugh like seeing it on
the thing because it was kind of funny
but I was like if I saw that in real
life I would probably like [ __ ] my pants
because that would be really freaky
although I kind of feel like
see that kind of stuff is almost
freakier to me than seeing like an
actual Apparition would be I know that's
like maybe a weird thing to say but I
don't know there's just something about
like the incongruity of that that's like
much creepier to me than it just seeing
like a [ __ ] ghost saying in there you
know yeah I probably [ __ ] my pants if I
saw an actual ghost too but I'm just
saying for some reason like just shoes
moving on their own [ __ ] like that is
like creepier to me
I don't know why
you did it do you get what I'm saying I
guess like I said because well because
it's more like incongruous like I said
it's more like it doesn't have as much
context I guess like if you see like a
ghost standing there you're like oh it's
a ghost you know what I mean but it's
like if you see something like that
you're like what the [ __ ] is that you
know what I mean I mostly just saw
things it wasn't just me my aunt my
uncle and everything just things thrown
from a direction where there was nobody
standing and weird phenomena mostly just
objects being thrown or objects
appearing and sometimes disappearing
within your field of vision but you
weren't quite looking at them at the
time when it happened which there's some
kind of quantum effect going on there
although some of the stuff that I saw I
was looking right at it but then in the
blink of an eye it was moving towards me
it hit me in the chest like that damn
big pin
that was weird he hit my chest bounced
off and then sucked back into the
cracking doors I was looking at it
through the crack of the door hit me and
went back in there
like man it was fast like a bullet and I
it made a lot of noise when it hit me
and red was standing right next to me
and I slammed the door after it bounced
off of me like [ __ ] through I
said you see that and he goes yeah and I
said that didn't happen and he goes yeah
I did and I said no it didn't that
didn't and I just pushed that out of my
mind I made I'm
I kind of tried to erase that event
weird but then I thought I imagined it
and I asked red I said did that pin hit
me and he goes yeah and then it went
back into the room
the the Poltergeist was mad because you
asked it to write something yeah I was
trying to get it to write something I
was watching that pin I thought that pen
was going to jump up and start writing
yeah I was across the room coming
tumbling and it hit me bow and went
right back in and I was 15 20 feet from
it
yeah pretty creepy wow wild [ __ ]
Zach says rare though they may be I love
stories of people who had hauntings from
kind or helpful ghosts I kind of like
those too actually maybe we should do a
whole show about that I was gonna do a
show about ghosts who solved their own
murders but I don't think it ever won
like in the in the thing I think we
talked about that one that was oh wait
no we did we did do a show about that
didn't we I think we talked about that
one but we found on off a Paranormal
Witness about the car that wrecked on
the side of the road and the mama died
that's yeah I think we were talking
about that and people saw the mama
standing on the road or laying in the
laying in the road and then they called
the cops and there was no woman laying
in the roads yes then they found a
little boy down in the down in in the
back seat
with the dead Mama that he had been in
there what a day or two oh no I thought
it had been longer than that other than
that yeah but yeah like she had run off
the road it was like a wreck yeah and
she had died and the wreck but the kid
was still alive so it's almost like they
thought it was on it I think it was on
Unsolved Mysteries it wasn't appear it
might have been on Paranormal Witness to
you but I'm pretty sure we saw it on
outside I thought she'd gotten abducted
or something but no she just uh
evidently fell asleep behind the wheel I
guess lost control of the car or
something yeah they're just the car spun
out when it went into like the woods
like into like a ravine nobody could see
it yeah and so yeah so like some people
were just like driving through randomly
and they saw like a naked woman yeah
like laying in the road and they were
like what the [ __ ] and then like they
stopped and then they couldn't see it
but they called the cops because they
were like we're pretty sure we saw a
naked woman like laying in the road and
then the cops came out there like look
we can't find anybody but then when like
while they were searching they actually
found out that car and they found the
kid who was like um still alive like in
the car even though he'd been there I
think he was in there three days
yeah I could be remembering it wrong
but um yeah I think we did maybe do a
show about ghost who solved murders and
maybe that was kind of like well that
wasn't really a murder that was just
like an accident but you know what I
mean the little boy said that he would
be in there with the dead mama he could
remember that he could see a big blue
glow
that's right around them both
can you imagine how [ __ ] horrifying
that would be like just being like in
the car with like your dead mom yeah for
like days and days he was a little kid I
know but still he said that he felt like
he was under he's being protected
if I remember correct they said the blue
Globe was yeah like she was hanging
around yeah like making sure that
somebody found yeah and that's that's
actually you know most people don't
become ghosts
or come back you
but a mother probably would
well there's a reason for it before she
moves on and joins up with the [ __ ]
great Cosmic Consciousness and
disappears within the sea you know I'm
sorry to make sure that nobody found him
yeah I see I had a near-death experience
and an out-of-body experience even
before that and [ __ ] I saw where you
go when you die it's like
it's just like a big ball of white it
better be cool
you know if you go in there you're not
coming back
but you're okay with it oh yeah you want
to go to it it's going back home type of
deal it looks like an ocean of [ __ ]
it's what the Greeks would call the
pleroma
the place from which the gods come in
return come from and return you're like
a cosmic Singularity outside space time
and [ __ ]
Zach says uh I wrote that down I love
that idea you could include Christina
Aguilera's too uh does getting someone
off count as being a helpful ghost
I guess so what did she what is he
talking about
did it didn't he mention earlier how
Christina Aguilera said that she had sex
with a ghost or I don't know like that I
thought he mentioned something about
yeah wrong drugs
[Laughter]
Tom Sykes said reincarnation is more
believable yeah I'm not really sure if I
believe in that or not but
I don't know I've heard some weird
stories but I don't know if I don't know
if I can make that final push we did we
did a show about reincarnation did we
not I think it was a while back but
based on my nde there is The
Reincarnation but it's
it's not all that linear it's not like
one life and you're not the same when
you come back every time you're not the
same person
you know because you don't have the same
just your Consciousness kind of [ __ ]
can inhabit a creature or a being and
live that life and then it goes back
into the pleuroma and then it could come
back out and it's outside space time so
you know
your next life may be in the past I mean
it may not necessarily be in the future
you know it might be in the past
and it may not be a human
one thing that they say a lot about it's
like I said I'm not I don't really know
if I believe reincarnation or not but um
I mean I'm leaning toward no but it's
just kind of like one thing that they do
say a lot though is that a lot of times
like kids will say creepy [ __ ] like that
they remember like past lives and [ __ ]
like that but once they get past like
five six seven eight years old they
don't talk like that anymore yeah so
maybe it's a thing where
you know if there's some other kind of
like thing and you inhabit some other
body like you can forget after a couple
of years yeah when I had that motorcycle
wreck I was in a coma
I had it I had a near-death experience
before the accident so I wasn't even in
there when the accident happened because
Ty's face is [ __ ] up but I had it he
popped out popped out before the [ __ ]
accident happened a couple minutes
before
maybe about a minute I guess
and how that happened was weird I
thought I was looking at my shadow but
it was actually looking down at myself
riding a motorcycle and then I would say
Where's that light coming from and
turned around there's a big ball of
light you now got me
and then I was in a place and there was
people that knew me there this big being
started talking to me it's kind of like
my guidance counselor I guess
[Laughter]
you got to go back you know
you know see behind him this big [ __ ]
white ball it all looked like it's made
out of welding arcs you know it's
[ __ ] super bright this big bright
ball and I could hear all this
I can when I say here you know just I
could feel all this singing and [ __ ]
coming from it kind of like singing
and then there were other ones around
they were talking to me
the ones that I knew
in some way I don't know if they were me
as past lives or people that I knew in
the past or I don't know what it was it
was just like a um an Entourage greeting
me
you know Tom's Posse yeah one of them
was a little it was just head and
shoulders they're kind of like statues
they weren't moving but they were
speaking telepathically and not images
and [ __ ] and one of them looked like our
friend uh what's her name uh I think I
told you about her already one with a
real cool costumes she moved away
uh you did a poster of her Olivia I love
Olivia she looked a little bit like
Olivia
when I saw Olivia I was like man it was
like that one it was talking to me it's
like hey everyone yeah she had a big she
had it the thing is it when I was sick
she had a hood on and braided hair with
all kinds of stuff in it with bone in it
bone little beads and [ __ ]
and uh she was more animalistic looking
because she had what's called facial
permit what's it called facial
prognathius where a slight muzzle and I
was looking at it I was like I could it
was easy that this being that was
talking to me and she was only about
four or something little
um that she was uh at least part in the
Avatar
so it was some kind of ancient woman
yeah there was somebody that I knew
but but pretty you know but kind of like
it was kind of an idealized
version of and uh like a part
Neanderthal looking woman
don't look like somebody Lord of the
Rings yeah yeah yeah
that is it that is very interesting yeah
a black cloaked lizard lady yeah maybe
not a lizard but maybe more kind of like
werewolfy or no she's look like a tribal
woman and she's yeah Zach said it sounds
like she looked like a picked Warrior
they were around during the single
digits entries in Scotland
I don't know if I was under the
impression that was ancient we were
talking about like tens of thousands of
years old like tens of thousands of
years ago
maybe so yeah maybe so
yeah I mean black cloaked lizard people
that's who we're going to be talking
about on the show today well the thing
about it is that here's the thing when
we first started watching this episode
and you know how they do the little kind
of like coming up on a haunting you know
it's kind of thing where they show you
like what you're gonna see like a little
bit of a trailer
um I was like wow this one looks kind of
silly but then uh when you watch the
actual episode A lot of the stuff they
showed in that was
not was a lot of it was like it happened
in a dream so you know what I mean so it
wasn't like oh you're having weird
dreams we were really like seeing this
stuff in real life so I was like okay
well that makes it like significantly
less silly so I'm kind of glad that they
have that but they did kind of make it
look like
I'm not gonna lie it's like it's
um because I do kind of feel like the
kid the littler kid
he did say that he saw the reptilian
thing like when he was awake right yeah
so
I don't know I don't know how I feel
about that but we'll see is that girl's
name again we're just talking about
Olivia Olivia yeah okay go ahead I'm
gonna try to fight a picture I mean she
moved away a while back but yeah I don't
remember I don't Where'd she move to
Tampa uh no she moved to another state I
think she got married I thought she
moved to Tampa and then maybe move
somewhere else
yeah she was cool she had a lot of uh
cool uh little outfits and stuff yeah
Tom Sykes says good special effects in
this episode yeah actually The Reptilian
makeup and all that kind of stuff was
actually really good and I was kind of
into like the old man ghost uh he kind
of reminded me of actually we were
watching the episode I said he's just
he's kind of like um you know in Creep
Show you know the episode Father's Day
where he's like banging his Cane on the
chair I want my cake Bedelia he reminded
me of that guy and it's like so I kept
going I want my cake I can see that deep
reminded me of because he was like an
[ __ ] like that uh but yeah
uh Tom Sykes has a grown version of the
daughter in this episode looked like
Andrea Peron kind of uh yeah I'm I
recognized
a couple of the actors I think one of
the ladies that was in this like I don't
think she had a speaking part but I
think she was in one of the episodes too
like I keep seeing the same [ __ ]
actors on this but do you want are you
still gonna like or you want me to like
start with this yeah you can start with
that okay oh we have a shout out too
because we got a new Patron last night
yay so it's we're we're whining about it
so I guess that helps
because we have been getting some new
ones so uh our new Patron is called
Tyron so thank you very very much yeah
thank you Tara becoming a patron yeah
because uh we need patrons
getting broke up in this [ __ ] getting
broke up in this yeah that's lost a lot
of our patrons over the past uh couple
years
lost about half of them yeah we
understand it in a [ __ ] economy's bad
and uh some people just get new ATM
cards so the
yeah then they don't think about it
because like I've had that happen too
where I was just kind of like I had to
get a new card because you know somebody
like stole my Identity or something like
that and then you know I was like oh
yeah I forgot that I was having like a
couple bucks taken out here and there
and I just forgot about it you know what
I mean it happens because I have money
coming out everywhere and I forgot I
went in the other day actually because I
was like I need to like save some money
and so I went in the other day and I'm
like now what have I been giving people
money to that I forgot about like
because you know just five bucks here
five bucks there that it kind of like
adds up and I went in there and there
was all kind of [ __ ] like I canceled
some of the bigger stuff that I
remembered like the AMC Stubs because I
was like I hate to cancel that because I
like having that but we just never go so
I'm kind of like that's like 20 25 bucks
a month that I were not using so I
canceled that and I canceled I had a
Netflix and I canceled that and there
was like some other [ __ ] too but then
there was like little [ __ ] like oh it's
like two bucks for this like Google
thing that I don't use and like you know
five bucks for this other little uh you
know membership thing that I don't use
and all this other kind of stuff and it
was like it ended up being like 45 or 50
dollars like added up so I was like well
[ __ ] I should have done that before
okay that's Olivia the woman I saw
looked like like that
yeah that's a good picture yeah I
haven't seen her in a long time but it
looked like welding Arc like like she
and and she wasn't moving it was like a
statue
but it had bone in her hair and like her
hair was all done and it was all braided
and it was like going through little
round bones and I could see all the the
work
and the weave in her Hood she had like a
hood she was wearing like a like a like
a hood on
and uh kind of like a cloak
you know but it looked like something
from tens of thousands of years ago it's
quite cool quite cool
facts that I still think the best ghost
on this show was the burned up dude
harassing the teen girl I had an idea
about him when I was little yeah that
was actually like a really good one that
was like a really good one yeah this has
got I mean it has some good moments you
know what I mean and actually this was
uh like I said I didn't remember hardly
anything about this episode but when we
were watching I was like that was pretty
good that was like a pretty good like
creepy episode yeah it was like one of
it was like something from the first uh
Five Seasons yeah because I was
expecting it to be kind of silly like
that like that stupid mummy one but like
you know yeah I keep breaking that yeah
the mummy The Mummy one and that dude
yeah with the [ __ ] with the lizard
man I mean this one alligator man a pep
yeah I mean this one had a lizard person
too to be fair but um at least 99 of the
time it was somebody's dream so I was
like okay I'll allow it it wasn't too
bad
but yeah so nightmare in the Attic let's
talk about this case
so this case concerns the fox family
now prior to them moving to the house of
Doom or whatever that's another episode
House of Doom I don't think there is one
called that but there probably should be
so they had been living in Iowa and I
guess they lived in a trailer
which like I said I'm not going to [ __ ]
on that because I grew up in a trailer
so you know so they ended up moving to
this little town called Lowell Arkansas
which I guess is in the Ozarks somewhere
and it's apparently like a pretty small
town I don't know I've never been to
Arkansas so if you're from Arkansas like
let me know where the hell this is so
this all happened in the summer of 1983.
so the mom and dad
um Carol is the mom she's actually well
when this show was filmed she was still
alive and she was interviewed on the
show uh Jesse is the dad he was not
interviewed on the show I don't know if
he was because he's dead or because he's
not around or because he just didn't
want to do it or I don't know
um so the kids at the time in 1983. uh
the daughter is named Mary and she was
17 at the time and the son is named
Wesley and he's eight at the time both
of them the grown-up versions obviously
are interviewed on the show so it's them
and the mom mainly
So what had happened was the dad Jesse
had got a job in Lowell Arkansas at a
cannery I think they said and the house
I'm assuming was owned by the company
and they rented out to employees like at
low cost which seemed like kind of a
good deal because they said that the
house was like super nice they said it
was like really really big and like
really gorgeous Mary actually called it
uh what she said was Gone with the Wind
Arkansas style yeah so it was like this
really really big place and they had
never like seen a house that big ever
and they like I said they moved from a
trailer so they were like really
impressed for you non-americans
the the the the southern Zeitgeist goes
all the way from like [ __ ] Texas and
Arkansas up into Kentucky Tennessee
Louisiana Mississippi Alabama
Virginia's Carolinas and then down into
Florida Panhandle then below that it
becomes basically Central America or
like the Bahamas
yeah but it's all real similar
you've got Regional differences but so
the Gone With the Wind thing that she's
saying yeah she's talking about those
old
kind of southern plantation Colonial she
said it looked like a plantation yeah
that's what she's talking about which is
it's a it's a house two-story house
usually kind of Victorian looking but it
has some porches that go all the way
around and there's big columns in the
front columns yeah and if it's a French
version it'll have another porch on the
second floor so it'll have two porches
the bottom porch and the top porch
That's pretty also they're still in the
French Quarter of those yeah I feel like
this one I don't know like the house
they showed on there it probably looks
similar to the one that yeah I mean I'm
imagining is the South got traded hands
so many times you know was native at
first
then Spain and France fought over it and
then it became kind of like then it
became part of the United States which
started to become more anglicanized but
you know there's this misconception up
north that the south is just
nothing but anglos no it's the Spanish
and the French too and Indians and
blacks and whites Irish Germans it's
everything it's all just mixed together
it's just a it's just a mixed area
but uh yeah so okay so they moved to
this place and they were like super
impressed at how nice this house was
okay now Mary she was 17. now she had
quit school
um I'm assuming she had quit school just
you know
soon like at 16 or 17. so she was the
one that took care of the house like did
all the housework and she also did child
care for her brother it was eight so she
like took care of him because both the
parents worked now I guess Carol worked
too but they didn't say where she worked
at they said the dad worked at The
Cannery but they said that both of them
like worked all the time so they were
gone a lot
um they also said like the family was
like super close but you know that's
about all they said now what Mary said
was that when they got to the house she
instantly fell in love with it um she
went in there she was just like this is
the best house ever and she still talked
about it on the show and she's like much
older obviously but she still talked
about it like it was the best place ever
so we'll get into that a little bit too
now uh she particularly wanted her
bedroom to be in the Attic like she went
up to the attic and there's like a big
room up in the attic and she's like oh
my god this is my room because it was
like really secluded it's had its own
staircase and I think she liked that it
was soundproof because you know she was
a teenager it was the 80s and so she
wanted to like play her music really
loud and not have anybody complain about
it so it was kind of like soundproof and
she really liked that about it
now later on
on the afternoon of the day that they
moved in presumably that's kind of how
they made it seem the parents have to
work like says I guess both of them have
got jobs here now
so Mary is kind of like working around
the house unpacking all their stuff and
like kind of looking after Wesley the
kid
so she's in the kitchen like putting the
dishes away and she said that she felt
like somebody was like in the kitchen
with her like behind her and she said it
felt like they were like standing really
really close to her like in the room so
she turns around and obviously nobody's
there
she said that she also then felt like
this really cold breeze kind of like
blowing her hair or something like that
like on the back of her neck and she
wasn't really sure where it came from
she said it was July when we moved in
here so it was like really really hot
outside this is Arkansas
um but she's like we didn't have the fan
on we didn't have the AC on there
weren't any windows open or anything
like that she's like but she didn't
really think anything about it she's
like well you know it's an old house
maybe there's like a draft or some [ __ ]
like that but she's like the breeze was
really cold so she thought it was like
super weird
so while she's doing that like Wesley
comes in uh and provides a jump scare
and then he's asked because you know you
have to have that every now and then so
he comes in and says hey I'm gonna go
right around the neighborhood on my bike
like go do some exploring and stuff and
she's like okay fine just be back for
lunch or whatever
so while he's riding around the
neighborhood on his bike
some of the neighbor kids yell at him
and they're like which I was very very
rude but they're just kind of like who
are you yeah you don't live here they
were like that
and uh yeah so I was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] I'm glad to like [ __ ] ride
the book okay Pokey what's the matter
we're we're busy what's the matter she's
got hey
she wants brush to be brushed oh my God
she discovered a new brush and no we
can't well she I can't I won't hear the
end of it I don't hear the end of it she
just wants it all the time now yeah see
there she is
um so yeah so like who the [ __ ] he's
like you don't live here and he's like
yeah I do we just moved to that big
house at the end of the block or
whatever
so then the girl that's there you know
the neighbor kid
she's like she's like oh I wouldn't live
there if I was you everybody knows that
that house is haunted and then the kid
or at least the actor playing the kid he
was like so funny there's no such thing
as yes and he gets all like indignant
about it which is like I don't know why
that was so funny to me what it was so
he just like kind of blows it off and
he's like there's no such thing as
ghosts I'm out here
so a few days later uh the house is
mostly unpacked and set up and
everything which like I said man they're
really on the ball with this [ __ ] uh so
the family they decide hey we're gonna
have like a barbecue so they invite like
some of their family and their friends
and like some of the neighbors and [ __ ]
like that over and they have like a big
barbecue in the backyard because you
know it's July
so one of the people at the party
was Christy now she was what I thought
they said this wrong but I watched it
again today and I'm like no they said
that it was correct they said that she
was Wesley's niece even though Wesley is
eight yeah and the niece was older than
him
it looked like I don't know I couldn't I
was trying to wrap my head around how
that happens but I'm not worried that's
what I'm sitting there I was like wait
did they say that it's the South I was
like did they mean that was his cousin I
was thinking it was a cousin but he no
he very specifically said niece that it
was his niece and that they were similar
in age now the actress that they had
playing her was looked like he was she
was a couple of years older than him and
I'm like wait a minute I mean I guess
that could happen I guess it could only
happen in a very big family but I'm too
dumb to figure it out right now
[Laughter]
like I was sitting there like all this
like I got really distracted I was like
wait how would that work yeah how would
I have a niece that was
yeah that was older than me I don't know
I don't know I mean yeah I guess it
could happen but I don't know so I just
thought it was a mistake but it was I
watched it again and they very
specifically your parents because your
parents have a lot of brothers and
sisters of different ages and I guess
that yeah it's only the only way it
could happen
I mean I have cousins that are older
than me and younger than me well yeah I
do too but that's not weird yeah
that's not weird but aunts and uncles
and [ __ ] no
aunts and uncles are all older than me
yeah that's the thing now I now I did
have an aunt that was only like maybe
seven or eight years older than me but
it's just kind of like still enough yeah
so but like I said if you have siblings
I guess that are way far apart in age
then I guess that could happen I have an
aunt I think that is
about eight or nine years older than me
that's the youngest one yeah that's what
I mean I have an aunt that's like the
youngest one I think she's how old is
that yeah she's not that much older than
me I think she's seven or eight years
older than me that's on my mom's side my
mom has nine sisters yeah my mom has
seven brothers and sisters talking about
a quiverpool family what they were they
were quiverful family religious family
well it's weird because my grandparents
multiplying my grandparents weren't
religious but they just happened they
just had a bunch of kids they just
really like kids I guess yeah one of
these times we're gonna do a show about
that Family
does he work he worked for NASA with
Donald Douglas and [ __ ] and all that
[ __ ] secret [ __ ] [ __ ] project
Orion Saturn project I got pictures of
him he was a trip and he was a religious
fanatic
that's who worked in those you worked
for the general atomics
because they trusted those guys if they
were if they came from if they were real
religious they trusted them because they
knew they wouldn't talk to the
Communists in in
um
and back in the Soviet Union Cold War
was on
Zach says if it says anything me and my
nephew are only four years apart in age
I mean yeah of see okay I guess that's
not weird I guess that's not weird but
still it's just like I don't know I was
like I I got really distracted by this
whole thing where he was saying oh it's
my niece and I was like yeah but she's
older than you and you don't usually see
that so I'm just like maybe they meant
cousin but no he said niece yeah like
very deliberately and he said they were
close to the same age so I'm assuming I
don't know it was just weird so anyways
so he's eight and she looked like she
was maybe 11 or 12 I guess like
according to the actress they didn't
have the real person on there
so the two of them are at this barbecue
and they're kind of running around
and they're like let's go look at the
creepy basement because you know that's
what kids do
so they're in the basement like you know
farting around or whatever and they find
this old school garbage can like the one
that Oscar grass lived in you know what
I mean like one of those old metal ones
yeah and they open it and there's like
ooh like a creepy doll in there because
of course there is I don't know if there
really was or if they was just like ooh
horror movie they have to have like a
creepy doll and everything so uh Wesley
pretends like he's trying to like freak
Christy out so he's like did you hear
that did you oh my God and she's like
what and then she's like blah and then
he's like with the doll so again like
they're using Wesley for jump scares a
lot in this one
um you know so she kind of Falls for it
but then she's like oh Wesley you
[ __ ] you silly thing
but then they see these old shoes
sitting on the floor that they
apparently did not notice before because
Wesley was like yeah I hadn't seen them
before and they were just kind of
sitting there in the middle of the floor
whatever just like old-fashioned looking
like men's shoes or whatever
now suddenly the shoes kind of start
walking on their own
as though I kind of pictured if it was
the Invisible Man except he was like
naked except all he had was shoes on
that's kind of what I thought like it
was just kind of so they were just kind
of walking like that
and uh you know not surprisingly the
kids are like what the [ __ ] and they
freaked the [ __ ] out and bring it out of
the basement as you would
so they run out and they tell their mom
Carol who's sitting at the picnic table
in the backyard but of course she
doesn't believe them she's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about the goddamn
kids you know what I mean it's that kind
of thing
um but they show that some of the
neighbors are kind of like talking
amongst themselves and they're like oh I
guess all the rumors are Trio should we
tell them about all the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
uh yeah no let's not do that so
apparently there are rumors around the
neighborhood I don't know how long these
rumors have been going on but that there
may have been a number of murders and
suicides in this house although they
really only specified like one
particular murder that took place and I
don't know if it actually happened or
not but they did say they checked and it
happened later but you know it was a
long time ago so it's kind of hard to
like check up on
so yeah so the most persistent rumor was
that there was the old guy from Creep
Show
it was like this [ __ ] that like lived
in this house this old guy that was like
constantly banging his Cane on the floor
and he lived in the house
on the show they said he lived in the
house with his wife and his mistress I'm
like both his wife and his mistress
lived in the same house
I'm like what are do you do you have
usually goes on do you have a death wish
is that what it is apparently he did
because either the wife or the mistress
shot him in the [ __ ] face yeah God
they were sick of his [ __ ] so I was like
all right back in the day you couldn't
get divorced
all right
divorce was [ __ ] bad so and you
didn't want to get rid of your wife so
you kept the wife you just got she was
the one doing all your housework
uh you know that was just work was very
gendered you know [ __ ] uh but you
didn't want to kick your wife out to the
wolves
so you got a new mistress and a lot of
times they moved in that's just the way
it was
um
but we know people that are like that
you're reading into it
we just call them Polly you know [ __ ]
Luke Bryan yeah but I'm sure you know
probably yeah but I'm sure it probably
wasn't the same situation back then I
don't know you're reading into it funny
yeah but and another thing well
obviously I'm not because one of them
one of them shot him well they do that
people do that no matter what so
evidently it it okay it's just I don't
know how much of a fun situation it was
a lot of time yeah this was the 1930s
yeah so well that was after the 1920s or
Roaring 20s was a sexual Revolution sure
but you're kind of like also I don't
know the situation that's what I'm
saying but you're pretending like you do
no I'm just I'm just saying anything's
possible I'm not gonna judge it in the
1950s way well I'm just saying I'm
judging it by the fact that evidently
one of the women shot him yeah well he
was probably being a dick it probably
didn't have anything to do with the the
living arrangements per se well that's
what I mean like I said maybe they were
just sick of his [ __ ] yeah because the I
don't like I don't know if like the
actor that was playing the old man like
the ghost old man if he had seen Creep
Show because because that was for real
like the energy if you don't know the
show real well I grew up in Brazil in a
Latin culture
and in a catholic-based society you
don't really divorce your wife you just
get a mistress but usually by the time
that that [ __ ] goes down that wife's
sick of that dude she doesn't
she's like thank God somebody else is
[ __ ] this dude that's usually what it
is okay they're like God Jesus well yeah
I know that's it I know what that is I
know that but it's like you're kind of
like I'm just like I'm just saying one
of them shot him so I don't know I don't
know and a lot of times the mistress and
the wife have a good relationship she's
just like yeah you take care of that
I got my own [ __ ] yeah you got one [ __ ]
to do and the wife's get she still has a
good living standards and she goes out
and shops and she's getting and a lot of
times she has a boyfriend
okay A lot of times she has a younger
boyfriend well I hope so yeah because
the Dude the husband is like yeah you're
go ahead have fun go have fun it kind of
puts the puts the wife out the pasture
just don't get pregnant and that's
that's that's usually the deal because
in a Latin Society it's a kind of a
disorder
to go through divorce you know just so
the family stays together you got kids
and [ __ ] so they just make it look good
on the surface oh yeah but everyone like
I kind of feel like they did that here
like a while back but they don't really
yeah yeah so that's probably what nobody
really bothers me anymore doing that but
you know what I mean yeah but you know
back then they used to so um so yeah so
in the 1930s evidently I don't know if
it was the wife or the mistress but one
of them shot him in the face yeah but
the way they like portrayed it was him
like doing like I said like a like a
Creepshow guy thing where he was like
banging the cane I expect my dinner on
the table and blah blah I'm just like
yeah you had that commentary so um but
whether this happened or not I don't
know but nobody apparently wants to tell
the fox family who are now living in the
house about the rumors about the murder
and or murders and or suicides which
they didn't bring up
but Mary did say that whenever they
would go into town
like to do something like they'd go to
the post office or wherever the [ __ ] and
they would walk in and it would be like
you know like in the movies where you
walk in the saloon and like there's a
record scratch and like everybody stops
talking she's gonna be kind of like that
yeah you know what I mean where
everybody just stopped talking but
nobody would like tell them anything and
I guess they didn't find out until later
on it's like everybody would stop
talking when they walked in
so a few weeks later Mary is up late in
the living room she's watching a movie
downstairs eating popcorn and whatnot
and then she notices that I guess like
the door from the living room like into
the hall or the foyer or whatever
um is open even though she's pretty sure
they're like sliding like double doors
she's pretty sure she closed them prior
to her coming in here
so at first she's like oh well maybe
there's just a draft or something maybe
they just blew open or it's an old house
or whatever so she closes them like it
happens a couple times but then she like
closes them and like locks it it's kind
of like remember the double doors on our
old house where one of them just kind of
like stays in place all the time and
then you just have one and it locks like
that just one locks and it's supposed to
keep them both room opening so it's like
it had that kind of situation so she
locks it but then and then she goes back
and sits down but then like the door
starts to rattle
and then there's like a key in it I
don't know if that was what it was
really like but the key term by itself
and then the doors like basically just
go shoot to just like fly open like that
so Mary freaks the [ __ ] out again as you
would and runs up to her room now the
reenactment actually shows the ghost of
the old man like showing up in the
doorway like hey what's up like looking
up the stairs like after she's running
away but Mary didn't say that she saw
that like she did say that she saw him
later but she didn't say that she saw
him at this particular time but I guess
they're kind of like
they are implying that she that that was
who did that
she said I thought this was an
interesting thing that she said she said
the feeling in the house was that even
though you paid the rent and you paid
all the bills on it and stuff like that
that you didn't belong there that you
weren't supposed to be here she's like
she got a very very strong feeling that
she didn't belong in the house or they
didn't belong in the house or they
weren't supposed to be there even though
they were obviously because they were
paying the rent on it
so once Mary gets back to her room like
all [ __ ] wigged out her mom comes up
and chews her out she's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing it's like I don't
know what time it was but it was like
really late at night she's like you're
running up and down the halls of this
you know ungodly hour you left all the
lights on downstairs what the [ __ ] is
your deal so apparently like the parents
were always giving her and her little
brother grief because they were they
thought they were making all these
noises that night because they're like
look we both have to work and we have to
get up early and it's like we don't
really appreciate being woken up but by
you like banging around and doing what
the [ __ ] ever
um but the kids are like hey it's not us
but of course like the parents didn't
believe them so apparently these noises
were like pretty common Carol who was
the mom she said that she heard the
sounds pretty often she said it sounded
like she said what it sounded like with
someone hitting the table that's what
she said and she said it was usually
around three or four in the morning and
she kept thinking that it was Mary like
banging around in the Attic room
so the reenactment showed that the sound
was kind of like the old the ghost man's
cane like tapping on the floor like bang
bang like he was like calling somebody
like bring him his cake you know what I
mean so that's kind of what they showed
but I don't know if that's exactly what
she heard because she didn't like
explain it but she said it was like kind
of noisy like someone hitting the table
that's what she said
so as the kind of what are you doing
she's trying to get up on the chair yeah
see her she's her little head pops up
every now and she's like hey what are
you guys doing she's like Daddy
come brush me
I do
oh Pookie yeah actually sleep I can't
sleep because she constantly crawling up
on me and looking in her face you going
to sleep yeah I'm going to sleep
but it's the middle of the night this is
prime Kitty time yeah yeah
complain all right I don't got time for
this [ __ ] she's [ __ ] funny man yeah
she well you know she like she's getting
better start making bread like that and
then she's looking around like she's
playing piano and then she starts zoning
out I said stop it stop it she said oh
oh what what what I was making my
business just making biscuits time to
make the business doing that [ __ ] like
that and she's sitting that right next
to me making biscuits on my [ __ ]
chest and [ __ ]
and I'm looking at her and she looks
like somebody playing piano it's
hilarious well that's why they have all
this like [ __ ] funny videos of like
cats it's a people have like made look
like they're playing the piano because
that's kind of what it looks like yeah
she looks like very very serious real
serious looking like your head's going
around
[Laughter]
like what's wrong with you look at like
Stevie Wonder All up in there yeah
but yeah
all right so um so as the weeks go by
these weird sounds banging sounds and
stuff like that like keep going on and
so the relationship between Carol the
mom and Mary the daughter like started
getting like really contentious they
were like arguing all the time mostly
because Carol thought Mary was making
noise all night and keeping her Mom
awake and she was like look I'm [ __ ]
tired all the time and it's like I have
to work and it's like what the [ __ ] are
you doing and Mary at this point I guess
she kind of got sick of like telling her
mom Hey look it's not me so she had just
started to like be like [ __ ] it and she
went all distant because she's like look
I know the house is haunted and her mom
won't believe her
and her mom just keeps yelling at her
and like blaming her for all the noises
so she's like what's the [ __ ] point
of like arguing with her but she's like
yep whatever you know what I mean it's
just that kind of thing and so like her
mom just thinks she's being an [ __ ]
but you know
so one night and like I said this is
kind of like where they showed like the
the trailer kind of situation at the
beginning and I'm like well that was
kind of silly but that's the reason why
it was because it was like a dream
sequence
and this is what they were talking about
so one particular night
Mary has this really really Vivid dream
and she said that she dreamed that she
was walking through the house and she
goes into her own room which is like the
attic only in the middle of the room
there's like a bunch of satanists
essentially
um standing there in the middle of the
room and all she said all of them had
black hooded robes on except for the
main guy who was wearing like a bright
red robe like in [ __ ] you know like
that [ __ ] uh Roger Corman movie
mask of the Red Death with Vincent Price
in it and so you know so there's candles
there's like a red Pendergrass you know
very satanic Panic this was 1983 after
all
so the whole gang of them are holding a
baby and I love like the
I just I don't know why I just like I
laughed at the baby in this because like
all the cultists are like holding the
baby they're obviously gonna sacrifice
the baby so the baby should sit there
going what it what are you guys doing
you know what I mean the baby's just
like totally unconcerned it was like I
thought that was like really funny but
yeah so they're all holding a baby
and uh they're chanting and [ __ ] and
they don't really appear to notice Mary
at all because like I said she's
dreaming this so she's just standing
there watching him like what the [ __ ]
and they're just all doing their thing
and like not looking at her now at this
point the narrator Anthony call uh he
says oh it seems like the house is
trying to tell her something because the
dream seems so real she didn't say that
but that's kind of what the narrator
said
so the red robed guy's face who's I
guess is like the leader of the Covenant
or whatever the hell this is it also
kind of turns reptile like a Sleestak
kind of situation that he has going on
there with his face like he has red eyes
and then he's like oh I'm a loser person
it was like that so and then stabs the
baby like picks up the knife and is like
God like they don't show it but you know
it's pretty strongly applied and so Mary
obviously likes [ __ ] screams her head
off
and she said so then she wakes up in her
room and she's like I felt like after
that like I felt like I would never
sleep again in my life it was the most
terrifying dream I ever had
now not too long after this Mary said
she started feeling like and this kind
of reminded me of that other uh episode
with that girl that was in the apartment
that said she was like sad all the time
but she said that she started feeling
like just bummed out all the time and
like really really sad and she couldn't
explain why
she basically said I felt like my whole
family had been killed in an accident
and like
so whenever she was in the house by
herself like she just felt like really
really super depressed and like bummed
out and she didn't really couldn't
really put her finger on my
so apparently her little brother Wesley
has also been weirded out by all of this
situation and uh for several weeks he's
actually been sleeping on a cot in his
parents room because he's too scared to
sleep in his own room
so one night he's sleeping on the cot
his mom is sleeping in the bed I guess
the Dad is working late I don't know
what time it was
so Wesley is like laying there awake on
the cot now his mom is asleep but then
Wesley looks up and sees one of them
hooded figures but weirdly this is like
this guy even though he's also reptilian
he has a black robe on whereas in Mary's
dream it was The Reptilian guy had a red
robe on so I don't know I know I'm being
like picky about it but I'm just saying
but he said so he sees a figure in a
hooded robe which is a black hooded robe
next to the bed and he said right
outright the real guy he said it looks
scaly and green like a lizard's face
that's what he said so he saw a lizard
man
standing next to his bed and he was
apparently awake
he said he was awake because he couldn't
sleep
this I have a hard time buying but okay
well it could take any image it needs to
I guess so I'm just saying if you dream
it all right but it's like you wake up
and you see like a lizard person
standing next to your [ __ ] I'm gonna
need a little more convincing some of
the stuff out of this case though sounds
like uh
sleep paralysis though
I yeah we were thinking that we were
thinking that yeah which um that totally
sounds like sleeper yeah and that
doesn't surprise me at all and that one
I've had sleep paralysis before I have
too when you get older you don't have it
as much
unless someone were to like shock you
out of certain stages of sleep
um but uh
haven't seen paranormal stuff and then
having sleep paralysis there is some
stuff that happens during plea sleep
paralysis that does seem to be
paranormal because you're in a certain
mind state
where paranormal could happen like when
I had that
the spontaneous Obe when I was in the
army
I was partially in sleep paralysis when
that was going on and there were
witnesses to that it was rspk
[ __ ] little mini fridge was shaking
and a damn microwave was popping and I'm
looking down at myself and I could see
dudes trying to wake me up
and then when I came back I was I was
paralyzed I couldn't even [ __ ] talk
so um
just because it's something seen in
sleep paralysis doesn't mean it wasn't
paranormal
because there's a gray area in that mind
state
so what I'm saying is is that you might
be in sleep paralysis but that helps you
access paranormal the Paranormal world
like what you're seeing that's kind of a
representation of what's really there
just an evil dude
uh you see him as a lizard man
you know that doesn't mean there isn't
an evil dude there or the spirit of an
evil dude
that's that's my take on Larry and
creature said guys tripped himself out
he probably just watched the Gorn
episode of Star Trek yeah maybe he had
dude the updated version of the Gorn
episode The Gorn blinks
because the in the original it's just a
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] up mask and it
doesn't but they made it so it blinks it
looks a lot better he does actually now
that I'm thinking about it like the the
lizard person in this does look more
like the Goran the Nestle yeah because I
was thinking Sleestak but
hey man in the mirror episode of
Enterprise it [ __ ] when Archer with
mirror Archer fights the Gorn by using
the [ __ ]
the gravitation plates so you could have
artificial gravity that was [ __ ]
great too everybody loves the Gorn yeah
yeah [ __ ] Archer fights his own maybe
you should dress up as the corn for him
the garm yeah I think I'd rather be a
slee stack though and maybe I should be
asleep
in uh in Enterprise the Gorn was CG so
it didn't quite look like it looked like
a dinosaur with clothes
it didn't look like it didn't look like
a dude no it didn't look a dude costume
yeah
it says
oh went down the wrong way uh this is
the third episode this is like the third
episode of a haunting with a pentagram
hidden under the carpet that's what we
started talking about yeah we said the
exact same thing like when they find the
pentagram under the carpet spoilers it's
true yeah we're sitting there going oh
man how many episodes is that now I'm
like uh hold back the carpet and there's
a [ __ ] pentagram how do you know
that's not a pentacle
there you go then it's good it's all
good maybe they've got it [ __ ]
oriented to a certain Cardinal Point you
don't know right exactly or you don't
know
it's just you know I'm not worried about
pentagrams
that's teenagers doing that [ __ ] and
that's and I kind of feel like I'll get
maybe we'll get into this a minute if I
remember but I do kind of feel like oh
pentagram under the carpet yeah if
that's like you said that's a truth yeah
that's turned up on several episodes of
a haunting maybe more than three I kind
of feel like I've seen it more than
three times yeah I kind of feel like
I don't know I'll get into it later
Venom and Motley Crew made that [ __ ]
mainstream in the [ __ ] metal scene
yeah and now you can go now this is 1983
so this is a little early but still I
kind of feel like that was still going
on and now you can go on Amazon and get
cutie pie [ __ ] girl goth clothing
with [ __ ] hoods and all kinds of [ __ ]
that has [ __ ] pentagrams all over it
and and I feel it which is crazy because
if you'd worn something with a pentagram
on it in 1983 everyone would have
spitted you yeah now you can get it off
of Amazon [ __ ] man like I said we you
know if if you're new here like you know
we were into the goth thing like way
back in the 80s and 90s we helped invent
that [ __ ] and people would like if you
were dressed weird like people would
throw [ __ ] at you from their cars and
stuff like they'd throw like beer
bottles and crafts free Marilyn Manson
they'd wrap you up and [ __ ] and even
when Marilyn Manson was going on they'd
try to [ __ ] you up and if you had and if
you were related with a pentagram or
something like that people thought that
was like you were that way yeah they
were trying to kill us all the time they
were you yeah so it's just kind of like
nowadays like I said I have [ __ ] with
pentagrams on it just because they're
neat looking like I have a I think I
have like a pair of kind of pleather
pants with like uh with them on the butt
I just don't wear them that much because
they don't fit right and so they slide
off but because they're too big but you
know what I mean
uh Tom Sykes says I watch those [ __ ]
that fit they look great on you I do
like them but like I said I can wear
them get you back on it I can wear them
as long as I don't move too much because
if I move too much they'll start to fall
because they're cheap I got a video of
her at the club with those pants on and
they're kind of falling down they're not
those pants but they're similar similar
kind of pants and it looks so cute with
her with with [ __ ] her pants [ __ ]
slide that she gets she gets so [ __ ]
been out of shape about well because
it's annoying having to like pull them
back up it's uncomfortable she's real
sexy when [ __ ] starts because I'm trying
I'm trying to dance and it's like gonna
have to keep like pulling up volume up
super cute super cute I know but it's
like super annoying I just want to like
concentrate on Dancing I don't want to
worry about my [ __ ] clothes yeah and
over the past few years Jenny riding
that damn bicycle and doing all the
[ __ ] anti boxes yeah her [ __ ] legs
look great and I'm saying she's gonna
show them legs off she's like she's like
I don't know put she you need to show
the sucking legs off Chad they're
[ __ ] great I'm gonna get a picture of
those why are we talking about this now
because we were just like started
talking about family she's getting
embarrassed well yeah why do you go
Jen's got great legs why are you always
go Jet's got great legs Richard Brown
said Gorn with the wind going with the
wind yeah I watched that movie yeah Tom
Sykes says I saw a cloaked figure during
my sleep paralysis dream as well but no
facial features or arms yeah just a
floating black cloak that resembled a
ring wraith yeah yeah when I had sleep
paralysis I saw
it looked like a person like it looked
like a human but it was just like a
shadow person but it looked like a real
person like carrying like with a
baseball bat yeah but the weird thing
about it is that even though it looked
like a real person even though it was
just like a shadow of a real person I
somehow knew that that wasn't like
because you think like if I woke up
because it's possible obviously that I
could have woke up in my apartment
because it's when I live by myself and
it's like if I woke up in my apartment
that was a dude with a baseball bat
stand in my bedroom door like on the
corridor like that could really happen
yeah but for some reason like I woke up
and I saw it there and I was just kind
of like huh yeah that's not there though
that's what you're thinking that's kind
of what I was like I don't I don't
really think that's there like even
though it looked like it was there I've
had one sleep paralysis where
um I couldn't move and I looked over at
the wall next to me somehow I guess my
head was pointed in that direction and
there was a face in that wall kind of
pushing its way out like something out
of it in a horror movie trying to say
something but it didn't scare me
that was like Nightmare on Elm Street
yeah but it was trying to give me some
kind of a message
um but the weird things that you see
when you're in sleep paralysis my take
on it have an experience with
Poltergeist and other paranormal stuff
it does it won't harm you it's actually
not there
but that doesn't mean it isn't
paranormal
it might be a psychic message from afar
in other words Jenny saw do with a
baseball bat there may have been some
dude somewhere with a baseball bat well
I'm that I'm just willing to bet yeah
substantial somehow somewhere something
happened and she was able to like
pick up on that and see it
he wasn't there at the time probably uh
good thing for me because I've been in
big trouble no I'm in the spirit of that
guy was not there but you might have
been accessing information
something maybe in the area or something
that was relevant to what you would ask
you kind of get what you ask for
and maybe there might have been a part
of you that was you know thinking about
true crime or just whatever you know
what I mean well it's not popped up fair
because I'm pretty much always wrong
that's maybe there was like this is you
don't know about this one what about
this guy remember this guy no you don't
know this guy right yeah nobody knows
about this guy so it's kind of like the
internet and Google searching it's kind
of like that
that's my take on it
um so some of this so the things that
you see in sleep paralysis
are real but they're not really there at
that time you might be but the
information behind them is probably real
and it may be paranormal
layering creature says uh dude Venom yes
love Venom [ __ ] right
I grew up watching [ __ ] listening to
Venom it wasn't the hell black metal do
you know the band pentagram they were
rad no I don't know that one I don't
know that one Hugo said my mom threw
away my shout out at the Devil album
because of the pentagram yeah see they
they were really like buttered about
that stuff back in the 80s I remember
that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
album when you look at when you actually
analyze the shout out the devil that was
weak sauce [ __ ] weak sauce that's
what I mean it's really nice it doesn't
sound like yeah it doesn't sound you
listen to it now and it just sounds like
regular [ __ ] rock music it doesn't
yeah it's just real yeah like everything
it says it's back I don't know like
everything's slowed down but okay
go ahead and drop us drop a message that
was weird did you guys see that yeah
we try to started talking about like
[ __ ] Satan did it I guess
hopefully you guys can still hear us
Larry kirchen said I used to get sleep
paralysis all the time as a kid but I
never had the person thing for me it was
like waking up in darkness being awake
inside your body but no ability to move
yeah I've only had it happen that one
time and it was like it was weird but
it's just kind of like I don't know like
it was scary but not scary you know what
I mean like I woke up and I was like oh
that looks like a real person like
standing there but I knew it wasn't I
don't know that's that's [ __ ] funny
that there's somebody that remembers
[ __ ] Venom yeah yeah
Conrad lent it was a guy who was [ __ ]
Kronos guy who did all the singing he
was The Mastermind behind it
[ __ ] he got big too he was [ __ ]
taking that d-ball and everything I can
see we got [ __ ] swole for a little
bit then he's back but [ __ ] Conrad
was a genius man he he invented black
metal
he was seemingly a good dude too and
didn't believe in any of that [ __ ] it
was all just [ __ ] well a lot of times
and it's just like well yeah it's just
like their whole that's their whole like
stick yeah I saw an interview and they
was like man they're like I'm not gonna
Slaughter The Virgins and [ __ ] it's like
a face this is a horror movie it's like
you watch the evil dead it's the same
thing I don't believe any of that okay
that's what I mean it's like well that's
what's so weird to me is that
I remember like one time like my mom
like read some of my horror stories or
something like that and she's like do
you really like think about that it's
like Mom it's a story yeah like it's
called imagination like you just make it
up I would never do any of that [ __ ] in
real life yeah I just like enjoy
watching it or writing it or reading
about it that's all
I would never do that stuff I showed I
showed Venom to Sophie Sophie listed a
couple of them she liked him she saw
[ __ ] Conrad she's like oh he's cute
yeah Conrad was cute but he [ __ ] had
a drug problem he kind of kind of tore
him up over a lot of people did that
yeah but when he was young you know
Conrad Conrad was [ __ ] head away with
women
yeah Zach said I've always thought the
worst part about hallucinating would be
seeing stuff you know isn't real but
it's still really upsetting like walk
into a room and there's human-sized
tarantulas everywhere yeah well that
probably would be upsetting but well the
thing about it though is that if you
watch if you knew it wasn't real yeah it
would be upsetting but you'd be like
well that's not really there when you
take LSD you know what you're I was
gonna say it's just it's it's maybe kind
of like when you do acid it's like you
see weird [ __ ] but it's like you know
you see weird [ __ ] but you're like well
I know that's not really there yeah like
at the same time so it's like ooh yikes
but yeah and I've done the steroid
version of LSD which is [ __ ] Trent
and Trend you have all kinds of
emotional feelings but you know they're
not true
you can't you know it's not true you
know you know you know your girlfriend
isn't cheating on you you know people
aren't talking about you you feel that
way but you know it isn't true
okay because
I'm older now you know my [ __ ]
frontal lobes are well developed I know
when I'm under the influence of
something you know and I've already
you're already researching what it what
it makes you do
you know so and how it makes you feel so
you expect it and it's the same thing
with hallucinogenics it's so weird to me
though that you can use your brain to
analyze your brain yeah yeah I think
about that a lot yeah yeah I knew I knew
what it was going to make me feel
because I'm always kind of like oh well
I'm kind of feeling like this or I'm
thinking like that but then like another
part of my brain is being like is
analyzing that and I'm just like that's
so weird that I'm doing that though
because it's like the same organ had I
not known beforehand it probably would
have been a lot harder but I was
expecting it to do that so when it does
it I'm going like oh okay it's doing its
thing I mean well that's good that you
like prepped yourself oh yeah yeah yeah
what's the same thing with acid LSD yeah
well I think we already knew what it did
well yeah and I mean I I kind of feel
like that's why I had a really enjoyable
experience on it because I I mean I'd
never done it before but I knew what to
expect what to expect and you were
basically like hey if you're like cool
with it and I was really like wanted to
do it so I was like came at it with a
really positive mindset so I had like a
really enjoyable that was years back I
had to watch her but she was good on it
yeah I mean it's good that you watch me
because like I said I was I wasn't gonna
do anything terrible I was just kind of
like I first wanted to go outside and
play in the garden and [ __ ] I wanted to
go roll around in the grass and be like
yeah like no no it is what I wanted yes
you got to stop
we have neighbors yeah yeah let's not
and then they [ __ ] they rang the
doorbell the [ __ ] mailman rang the
doorbell to [ __ ] give me a mess to
give me a [ __ ] package I had to sign
for and that was like we were hiding
from the mail holy [ __ ] that was oh [ __ ]
we still laugh about that
I go out because we it was I go up there
to explain to the mailman look man
really high on acid right now he starts
laughing they're not going what do I
have to do because just sign right here
and it says okay I'm really he's like
I'm really [ __ ] up on a LSD right now
this is my house man I'm gonna tell you
I'm high on Ella's knees well
time because
because it dropped on it was like a
Tuesday afternoon or something because
it's like we were both off work and
we're just kind of like we had some like
from our friend and we're like Hey we're
gonna we don't have anything to do today
because we were both off work and it's
like let's do this and so we did that
and then like we're like an hour or two
into it and yeah somebody rings the
doorbell and at first we were like oh
[ __ ] like we got all [ __ ]
[Laughter]
before I do this I'm really high right
now
as you are because yeah I'm really high
on LSD and he goes just sign right here
Amanda Bear right and every time I saw
that same UPS man he's like what's up
man
because I remember you trying to sign
because you had to sign for this [ __ ] I
don't even remember what it was but in a
damn [ __ ] computer and he's like
like his eyes off yeah oh my God I came
back here because he's gone yeah he's
gone
but it was funny how immediately like we
heard the doorbell and I was like holy
[ __ ] is that the cops
[Laughter]
and then like we run in the closet we're
trying to like look out the window and
stuff I'm like oh my God we're in
trouble
I don't know it was like it's [ __ ]
hysterical that was hysterical
um all right so I kind of lost my place
what else is new
oh we oh okay so we got distracted by
the whole Lizard Man situation because
we're talking about the Gorn and all
that we're about halfway through this
aren't we
um more than half leaks okay and I'll
tell you what you know it's a good time
for commercials we gotta do some
commercials all right we're gonna I'm
just gonna do one set though all right
and then you can go ahead and go to the
restroom and go the restroom and all
that kind of stuff all right we're gonna
do some commercials and then we will be
back in just a moment we don't have that
much left out of the case so we're gonna
do some commercials and we will be right
back in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
prices
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right we're back yeah I hope you
guys enjoyed the break I think I forgot
the when I was doing the first string I
was like I think I cut it off like
before one of them but I will I forgot
which ones like I put it all on there
but Larry's in there saying that um
the black metal genre got his name off
of [ __ ] the Venom album yeah it was
called black metal I think it was their
second album
and he said that they were from
Newcastle UK near where he's at
well there's a lot of cool [ __ ] came out
of the UK during that era because uh
public education in in England and
offered music training
so
a lot of good dudes came out from that
generation you know that come out of the
the British educational public education
system
[ __ ] [ __ ] man [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] ton of them [ __ ] Bowie
Pink Floyd
or anything heavy metal came from there
you know Judas Priest and like I said
I'm really into the whole Post Punk yeah
New Wave yeah all that [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] was good yeah because even even
what they called the shitty [ __ ]
bands that came out of that generation
which have been Generation X with Billy
Idol they're not shitty they're awesome
well Generation X was shitty okay but
Billy Idol moved to the United States
and became great because he got good
backing he got help of [ __ ] Steve
Stevens helped him with writing and
everything and he was just
idle [ __ ] William Broad and also
knows Billy out he says I just think
he's a great dude
even even with all his drug problems
still was able to produce a lot of
really good [ __ ] uh which always amazes
me when people that are really yeah
because man I have like three or four
drinks and it's like I'm [ __ ] useless
so I can like really really admire
people that can just be hey I'm on I was
on heroin yeah
and I still put out like brilliant apps
like yeah look at like Nick Cave for
crazy who was like completely [ __ ] up
on everything and he just produces like
[ __ ] genius [ __ ] like all this time
yeah I mean Billy Idol was that blessed
My Mind Billy Idol was basically born
addicted to heroin he's like 15 and on
that [ __ ] and he's still living but in
Duran Duran I mean [ __ ] England was
uniquely they were more like coke heads
weren't they yeah they were into
everything but most Coke John Taylor was
the worst of those I kind of feel like
the other ones I kind of feel like had
maybe minor but anybody that had money
in the 80s was it was everybody was
snorting drugs back then that was a
reason uh
but England [ __ ] was uniquely
positioned to [ __ ] conquer the earth
when it came to the music music and
entertainment but mostly just music
although
they needed the American Market to get
it done England is too small there's not
enough money to be generated there well
in the United States and [ __ ] the
thing about the British Market is that
it's it's harder to break in well
because their [ __ ] is like National yeah
you know what I mean fickle too they'll
throw a good act away because like well
that's done
I don't know if that so much happens
nowadays but it did happen like a lot in
those days I remember
yeah uh Larry and creature's a Black
Sabbath for sure oh yeah man Post Punk
stuff like Joy Division you just
mentioned two of my very favorite bands
in the whole world and honestly like not
a lot of people I feel like a lot of
Americans are not into the fall uh R.I.P
Marquee Smith by the way but I I don't
know I really got into them I don't know
what it is but
I was like related to the fall I love
Joy Division I love
um all the goth Rock stuff I just Post
Punk is probably like my favorite what
the [ __ ] she just came out of the damn
she's just a cabin comes out of the cat
how'd you get in there how do you think
with her little with her little hands
yeah Larry creature said I [ __ ] love
the fall yeah it is so good yeah I do
too yep and I have like I wish I could
afford all their albums I have like a
good The Furs I have like a good chunk
of them but I mean they put out an album
like every well no they put out like
three albums a year or something oh
thank you now the money starts coming in
thank you very much thank you Trey you
gotta love a Duran Duran mention oh and
it was John who was the cokehead yeah
that's what I thought I thought
of course I think they all down they did
but like I said John actually had like a
problem yeah where they were all like
bro and uh I was into them man and
[ __ ] I I like one of their least
popular albums it's [ __ ] notorious I
love that notorious album I like it now
well I didn't like it when it came I
loved it well okay I'm not gonna go that
far when it came out 1987 I bought it on
vinyl because I'm old and listened to it
and I was like
I like it but I don't love it
um I like it more now like I appreciate
it more now to me because this was the
80s and I was more into like I liked
their first album I liked Rio seven the
Ragged tiger was good too but it's like
at their first two are like my still my
favorites like after all this time but
it's like when notorious came out I said
it sounds a little too I liked it shardy
I loved it it was a whole album too much
saxophone oh I loved that it was oh no
they brought in the wind instruments and
everything they got rid of some of the
Dead weight it was now Trio and they
were they were doing good
[ __ ] um and it was an entire album
about hookers [ __ ] and blow hooker
[ __ ] and Coke that's what that album
was about well that was kind of their
hole Yeah I mean
you know I mean well I guess Rio was
more like
more veiled references
right very sophisticated and we're rich
now yeah we're like we're from the hood
but we're on yachts and what yeah yeah I
love Duran Duran I'm just gonna say oh
yeah thank you thank you the second
coming of The Beatles really he said he
read John Taylor's book yeah yeah I had
heard that like I read a lot of books
about Duran Duran like a long time ago
but I haven't read any since then but
yeah I heard that John Taylor was one I
think they were all like kind of I don't
know if I'd call them druggies but they
didn't really have problems but I think
John Taylor really did well they were
regular guys for that era that's what I
mean so like everybody was awesome it's
just that some people like overdid it
just a little bit some people are kind
of predisposed towards addiction other
people can resist it like I can walk
away from anything
I mean I I [ __ ]
done opium and [ __ ] I've never injected
heroin I don't think I could walk away
from that one
but I've done pretty much all of them
and I'm not really have it for me the
closest one that got me would be Coke
snorted it
on several occasions and I always wanted
more you're like the next day this is
awesome
I want more of that but I've only done
it once but it wasn't like great you
didn't have good [ __ ] that's what I mean
it wasn't good [ __ ] so I was just kind
of like whatever and I'll snort that for
a whole night I was snorting it with
[ __ ] the barbiturates from [ __ ] uh
from Boston they were
sex act type group [ __ ] from sleep
they were the backup
girls for Sleep chamber which was kind
of an industrial band from Boston
and uh just free Coke all night and the
next morning I [ __ ] still wanted some
I said man I could use some of that coke
because I just felt like I was just
dragging drag-assing around [ __ ] and
I had to go out to the club so my
solution was to just drink
and you can drink yourself into
forgetting about cook and then the the
third day you don't sound super happy
you don't care yeah you don't care so
that was I learned that you can drink
you can drink yourself into forgetting
about Coke okay well you can drink
yourself into forgetting about pretty
much everything yeah that's one of the
nice things about it you got to be
careful you got to be careful for Coke
and [ __ ] I wouldn't [ __ ] with Heroin
I heard that once you get it which we
drink a lot on this show Larry in case
you didn't realize once you get a taste
the heroin you're probably we don't
drink on every show but on most live
streams we do and on the Monday once we
do because it's like the fun ghost we
actually don't drink that much
well when we're not on the show we're
not drinking when we're not on the show
and when we're not out at the club like
we drink it those two times but the rest
of the time's not so much yeah I have I
have I have Muslim [ __ ] fans going
you need to stop drinking they're
worrying about me I said dude man you
don't know what you're talking about
right this is lightweight [ __ ] compared
to what we would normally do and I could
walk away from that that's no big deal
it's because they're under the
impression that you're drinking all the
time yeah we don't drink every day it's
not like I wake up and I'm just like
where's my booze yeah it's just kind of
like when we're doing the live stream we
drink like well not on everyone because
the movie reviews we don't usually drink
on those yeah we'll usually drink on
this one and the main show and the
sidetracks and if we go out we go out to
clubs probably once or twice a month and
then we'll drink a lot there but it's
like other than that not we don't really
and you know
coming up on my mid-50s but
my blood chemistry is not that of a
normal human I mean I can [ __ ] just
recover in a few hours from anything
it's almost superhuman
since you start going on HRT and you're
doing [ __ ] steroid cycles [ __ ] in
middle age not big Cycles but whatever
you just you can just shake anything off
you're just so strong
metabolically
so it's not a problem people don't worry
about it my Islamic friends do not worry
about it yeah we're fine it's fine we're
not alcoholics no we might we're caught
we're drunks but we're not alcohol yeah
big difference there's there's an
alcoholic takes a drink and they drink
themselves until they [ __ ] fall I
mean well I would consider an alcoholic
yeah you know and like I said I'm not
[ __ ] on it because that's like
that's bad that's like that's that's a
tragic situation I consider like an
alcoholic is somebody that like wakes up
in the morning and the first thing they
think of is like where's my booze yeah I
don't do that they usually don't live
long a true alcohol we usually are like
when it's the evening we're doing a show
or we're doing something or we're just
like watching a movie or we're like
relaxing oh we'll have a drink or
something like that so I kind of feel
like that's the difference like we don't
need it another thing is is that we're
at least 90 something percent European
and genetically we already born with an
inborn resistance to it it's not like if
you're a Pacific Islander and I got
Pacific island friends on there they
know exactly what I'm talking about
[ __ ] we had guys in the Army from the
Pacific Islands just one Drake and they
just [ __ ] lose it want to shove their
head through walls they want to kill
everybody
it's not the same kind of like a Native
Americans uh
yeah some people have a hobby we've been
around our ethnic background has been
around for thousands of years under the
influence of drinking wine beer and
distilled alcohol so we already have
come from a long line a long line and
people have been drinking this so we
have a resistance to it okay it doesn't
quite not me personally because my
parents actually did not drink yeah well
what it is is that all the people that
were predisposed for [ __ ] up under
that [ __ ] are dead are dead they're dead
they didn't have any disabled widowed
out yeah yeah
um Larry and creature said British
Invasion in the 60s too like The Kinks
the animals The Beetles yeah so good I
love all that [ __ ] I love all that [ __ ]
uh Brits were
they had an Empire that [ __ ] the Sun
never sat on
during the 1617 even in the 1800s they
[ __ ] their trade Empire was [ __ ]
badass but that faded all right
and then it moved into what what the
British really conquered the world with
was that [ __ ] artist their music
[ __ ] great music especially in the
English-speaking world not even the
English-speaking World growing up in
Brazil I mean they were listening to
British music British heavy metal
british-based New Wave type [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] that was considered to be
real artsy farts I mean that was like my
first
like when I was growing up because you
know I was born in what 72 1972. so when
I was one of the 80s were just
burgeoning yeah MTV started like all
that bro all the British New Wave all
that kind of stuff and my dad was real
into the Beatles and was real into was
like into like a lot of that British uh
music too like he was into kind of like
southern rock too which I still don't
like yeah but he was into like um a lot
of the British stuff too like The Kinks
and the Beatles and he had all those
records so I heard those a lot when I
was a kid and I still love that [ __ ]
like I wasn't the UK faked southern rock
some Rolling Stones in a way there's
this kind of like better yeah this some
of the Rolling Stone songs you know I
mean like wild horses the fake fake
Southern Accents and [ __ ] but then there
was a there was a Scottish band Nazareth
yeah yeah which sounded most most
Southerners think that that's a southern
rock band
I had to correct a guy says no Nazareth
is uh is Scottish and they were like
what yeah that's not Southern that's
that's Scottish
it's a cultural exchange because like I
said yeah the British and the
Australians too like maybe even to a
larger degree because you have stuff
like you know Nick Cave in the birthday
party and people like that yeah that
were real into like Americans like Roots
rock and blues and stuff like that and
so they kind of like did their own take
on it yeah and like reflected it back
into it and like a lot of that was
really good but Nazareth [ __ ]
unfortunately those dudes all died
basically in obscurity
even though they had a [ __ ] ton of fans
yeah [ __ ] kind of sad but uh no that
was a good Scottish band they were
[ __ ] great Gene Loves Jezebel another
good Scottish band no they're well well
sorry they're well all right I would
know because you wouldn't know you would
know because I I lived in Wales for a
while yeah so I would know they were
Welsh the twins the Aston twins yeah we
met I met one of them
yeah we did I don't know which one it
was it wasn't it was just in the past
couple months a couple months yeah yeah
I think it would think it was Jay J yeah
it was Jay's version of Gene Loves
Jezebel they played here in Orlando yeah
and it was good small
small venue one of my favorite small
places he was super happy that like we
knew all of his old songs yeah he was
real impressed I I went out to him
before before he even started playing
when the opening band was on he was kind
of sneaking around like nobody knew who
he was and I said look man I just shook
his head he was kind of scared of me
because of how I look I guess
but uh because I forget how I look I
don't look like a goth dude anymore I
look like a [ __ ] wrestler
shook his hand and I said look man um I
grew up listening to your music man
[ __ ] The Immigrant and Porter you
know the Immigrant album and uh discover
and discover yeah and I said uh we kind
of got it somewhere and I said I know
that was a long time ago but we kind of
grew up together man and [ __ ] I just
wanted to thank you for for the work
that you and your brother did
and he was he was [ __ ] jacked he's
like you know my work it says yeah
yeah I know see that's the thing because
I think I knew his work right well I
kind of feel like they're always
surprised yeah yeah and I said yeah but
everybody like when he played like the
the old [ __ ] like he knew all that like
the cow oh he picked the cows you played
the cow he's on stage yeah I played
part of the crowd left and it left about
[ __ ] 50 all these old [ __ ]
yeah all the old [ __ ] are about
50 or 60 of us like oh my God I remember
this we were jamming through the whole
[ __ ] concert oh my God it's so funny
yeah and uh he was great live even
though it was just one of them it was
only half of that because there's two
Gene love Jezebels now the the two they
were twins the Twins and they started
fighting each other basically over
they're fighting each other basically
over who was in the band they didn't
well that happened they couldn't agree
with don't start a band with your
brother okay because Oasis and your twin
brother Jane Loves Jezebel yeah or Gene
Loves uh Jesus and Mary Chain that was
another one that was brothers that kind
of like they got mad at each other
constantly fighting over who should be
in the band so you know yeah I have
siblings but I love my brothers yeah uh
yeah so yeah I got way behind Okay yeah
I [ __ ] love to fall one of my
favorite bands and I think he said like
we blew his mind like saying that we
knew who that was and we were really
into it like seriously the fall is one
of my favorite bands and I feel like lot
of people like apparently like a lot of
Americans don't know who it is but it's
I really really like them a lot
and uh Larry encourage that Marquise
Smith was booze and amphetamines yeah
yeah he didn't he didn't last too long
but uh yeah wow this is good too yeah
man they're uh they're an acquired taste
I get that they're because Trey just
said that's yeah they're not for
everybody
um yeah they're really not like I said
they're an acquired taste but I'm I
really really dig them I like all other
[ __ ]
yes that's a plug to Gene Loves Jezebel
too if I can go check out that [ __ ]
discover album or the Immigrant album
Trey says MTV 120 Minutes in the late
80s got me into them Larry yeah I kind
of feel like maybe
I don't know if it was that it probably
because I loved 120 minutes and I
thought maybe because they did that
cover of The Kinks song Victoria but I
kind of feel like I got into them before
that but I can't remember
I think what got me into them was
actually
uh the I am curious orange album
um that the ballet they did with Michael
Clarke
you know what I mean I'm talking about
the fall now uh you know they did that
song uh new big Prince and I really
liked that I mean I thought that was
great and I think but I think honestly
the first CD that I bought because I was
into the fall before this but like the
first CD that I bought was extra Kate
which I think came out in 1989 and I was
like so excited my first CD and it's
like it was a fall one
um they're talking about Coke holy crap
I'm like so behind and we haven't even
like finished the case but whatever
[Laughter]
yeah uh in the UK regular drinking is
just good social etiquette yeah I kind
of feel like
that's kind of what we do it's just it's
just
social drinking like I said we're not
we're not the kind of people where you
just like wake up in the morning it's
like oh my God I need a drink or I need
this and that it's like you know it's
usually when we're just like chilling
out with you guys or we're just like
relaxing watching a movie we'll have a
drink or two or something like that or
when we're out like when we're out of
club dancing and then we'll have a bunch
but it's like other than that
not so I don't think about it otherwise
you know what I mean
uh yeah Larry and creature said yeah man
that's the brick Smith era curious
orange era yeah um still my favorite
album of theirs
um probably is uh the wonderful and
frightening world of the fall from 1984.
I think that's probably still my
favorite although this nation Saving
Grace is good too but um but yeah I
think that is my favorite that's the one
I listen to the most often I tend to
like their older [ __ ] but because I kind
of feel like they went a little bit more
I don't want to say like techno but they
had like a little bit of a
I don't know a little bit more of a
techno vibe to them which was good but
like not I didn't like it as much I also
like newer stuff too and so I think
Jenny still kind of keeps up with stuff
but I'm liking to uh
I'm big into some of the newer
metal bands from the south like Amy Lee
and Evanescence big into them
they're not that new though they're not
that new but they're still she's still
around Amy's still good I'm just that's
newer than what we're talking about
that's true um fly leaf I was you know
[ __ ] Lacey storm [ __ ] love her
[ __ ] I was trying to [ __ ] wanted to
see her live
I can't believe that these people are
all in their [ __ ] 40s now yeah I see
them as like young you know
but uh well there you go there's a lot
of good Southern
metal acts out there there's a lot of
good everybody yeah yeah that's what I
mean but it's just it's harder to find I
feel like nowadays just because there's
so much good stuff
I mean back in the old days you know
yeah people like to you know I'm not
saying that it wasn't awesome back then
because it was because there was a lot
of Awesome music but it was easier to
find I feel like in a way it was like
harder to find and easier to find at the
same time like now it's easier is
there's so much more out there but it's
like more difficult because there's so
much of it there's like so much static
that you have to get through and then uh
good local band that Jenny and I have
supported and worked for and I helped
discover got those [ __ ] signed which
is a starry night
who are from yeah they're like a goth
band they're goth kind of like our
version of The Cure uh they're from
Miami Miami and they're a bunch of cool
Hispanic American guys Cuban American
type guys and [ __ ] they're just if
you like the Cure and you like [ __ ]
post-punk and you like that kind of
stuff you'd probably yeah you'd love a
starry night it's called
a-s-t-a-i-i-n-i-t-e yeah it never said
a-s-t-a oh you spell it right n-i-t-e
and they got a bunch of videos out and
Jen's done uh several of their CD covers
and some of their shirts I think so we
we've worked with them and we've seen
they're super nice dudes yeah good dudes
good dude
um but our friend Imani was like Tom
what's the best band in Florida because
she was trying to get them signed
through this New York label that she was
hooked up with at the time and I said
the best thing going on in my opinion is
a starry night
she signed
signed him to their first label they
left that label though they went they
were they're now well now they're on the
guy the guy no they're on um you know
the guy from uh dasek yeah his what is
his label called in Germany I don't know
I think they're on that label now okay
Bruno cram oh that's that guy's name
they've been on several legs because I
like docs too but yeah they're on that
they're on that guy yeah but astari's
really good all right you guys they just
put a new video out a couple days ago
yeah I just saw it on the [ __ ] uh Larry
says you ever hear about the first ever
psychedelic rock band oh 13th floor
elevators yeah that's like uh Rocky
Erickson
um I used to have I don't know if I
still have it somewhere I have so much
crap in here but it's like um remember I
don't even remember when this was late
80s early 90s there was like a cover
album like a bunch of bands that cut
like covered Rocky Erickson songs and I
had one of that because I had heard of
him because I was really into Julian
Cope and the teardrop explodes and
Julian Cope was really into Rocky
Erickson so I got into Rocky Erickson
because of that you know what I mean so
that's usually how that ended up
happening man I've just drawn a blank
because I've been drinking but
what was that band we bought their
shirts and I [ __ ] love those dudes
and [ __ ] um
you got one of their shirts I met them
they started playing that [ __ ] song
and I was like oh I know who you guys
are but I hear it all the time a new
retro wave remember that way yeah yeah
and Absolution Corey
k-o-r-i-n-e I mean that's like if you're
into like that synth yeah new retro wave
is what they call it it sounds it's like
that if you go on YouTube and go look at
look up chlorine with a K
k-o-r-i-n yeah I like them a lot too
they're awesome they're from up North uh
but I talked to them they're [ __ ]
really cool dudes and [ __ ] bought a
shirt from them and um
uh but I was jamming to him before I
didn't even knew who they were and then
they showed up here to do uh
solution like their goth Festival three
days we had to make a couple hundred
t-shirts for that event me and Jen did
and wow that was a nightmare
we had to do it all in one night yeah
and I was like with the [ __ ]
screaming
we were already [ __ ] frazzled and
[ __ ] and then we showed up to the event
and [ __ ] I'm passing out all the
shirts because our [ __ ] friend
ordered them all and uh I'm seeing these
skinny mother and skinny young
long-haired [ __ ] gender-banded
[ __ ] up there singing and [ __ ]
and all of a sudden
um that [ __ ] song that I [ __ ] love
they started playing like I was like
that's them
uh I can't remember that heaven's
service there you go Heaven's servant
that I [ __ ] love that song
and I mentioned chlorine earlier about a
year ago on on the show here and
somebody thanked me for mentioning that
band that that's the that's that that's
their favorite band now I think they
might be good I think they might be from
either Seattle or Portland I don't
remember which one I remember where
they're from either but they're real
good and they're so we talked to them a
little bit because I bought one of their
shirts like if you're a Generation X and
you liked the way music was
those dudes are [ __ ] like I said if
you like if you like that retro like 80s
kind of iob yeah they're really into
that Larry says how often do you guys do
this stream we do
uh we do a lot of we do streams three
times a week no more than that we do a
movie review on Sunday we do this one a
haunting Mondays even though we're not
even talking about haunting anymore uh
we do this one we do a movie review on
Tuesdays we do the main show on
Wednesday which is usually
true crime or paranormal or weird
history or something like it's usually
like a topic uh this the topic this
Wednesday by the way is the Mormons
that's what we're going to be talking
about this Wednesday
and then yeah and then on Friday night
we do what we call a Side Tracks which
is this which is us talking where we
just go where we just get drunk and like
talk about whatever like it doesn't
happen we're doing what we're doing
right before usually before we're going
to go out so it's like five days a week
we usually do these and we put up like
recorded videos at various times also
yeah Zach says I just realized this has
turned into a Sidetrack show yeah yeah
yeah yeah well we're almost done with
this I mean we were almost done with the
case I'm just saying but it's like
sometimes like you guys ask questions
and I get like all interested in them
like yeah
that Larry said nice I'll be tuning in
for sure yeah we're pretty much always
on here you can't avoid us so there's
that but yeah but if you see the show to
any extent like we try to well I try to
have a topic for some things like for
example yesterday we did a show about
Godfather 3.
that was a movie talk and I think that
we kept it mostly on topic I was proud
of us yeah
um tomorrow we're going to be talking
about Todd Browning's freaks from 1932.
uh but are you gonna see that tonight
yeah it means we're going to wrap this
up because I gotta cook too what time is
it it's uh 7 41. okay still early we're
almost it feels late because it's been
dark but yeah well I mean we try to stay
on topic but
it doesn't usually happen so
[Laughter]
why we started doing the Sidetrack show
because I was like oh well we'll get all
our yeah all our Sidetrack energy out on
this one show but that's not how it
works this is part of the show though
that's what I mean and I kind of feel
like maybe a lot of people like that
because the same people like come and
tune in every like time that we do this
so it's interactive the show's
Interactive
I mean this reality show
yeah Larry said classic movie I think
Todd Browning did White Zombie too I
don't remember if he did white zone we
just did uh we talked about his version
of Dracula we also talked about Spanish
Dracula because we went through a thing
where we did like some 30s movies with
the mommy and we did yeah Spanish rock
is good also yeah I really like Spanish
actually but um I've been wanting to do
freaks for a really long time so
because uh because that's a [ __ ]
classic that's on HBO Max so we're gonna
watch that tonight so we'll talk about
that
um yeah
Larry said yeah man somehow the Goran
novice of course it doesn't matter what
it is it's always just something we'll
take one thing and we'll just like
[ __ ] run with it if that's just
that's how [ __ ] happens I mean if if
this shit's going to how much longer do
you think it's gonna take I don't know
we'll see I'm look look at my little bar
because I gotta start getting that
[ __ ] meat ready down there yeah he's
got to cook that's what you're saying
okay so we're gonna finish this up I
swear to God we're gonna finish this
we're talking about okay we're almost at
the end this one had kind of I'm gonna
say this episode had a little bit of an
anti-climactic ending so we got like
distracted by The Reptilian which you
know understandable I get it
so yeah reptilian's gone he wakes up and
probably don't and nobody even remembers
don't talk about anymore but he wakes up
and he sees The Reptilian right
everybody remembers that so then like he
his mom is in the room too but she's
sleeping so he goes over there he's like
oh my God there's like a [ __ ]
reptilian like next to my cot but she
won't wake up for whatever reason next
to my [ __ ] no caught okay all right yeah
you just thought there was a reptilian
next year there's a little reptilian
right there damn that's what you know
that's what you were thinking but yeah
so um so his mom won't wake up so he
Dives back into his cot and he just like
pulls a blanket over his head because
he's eight you know what the [ __ ]
uh so he later tells his mom is like
look oh my God I saw like a dude in a
hood that like looked like the Gorn or
whatever but of course she doesn't
believe him because you know she's a mom
and that's what they do they don't
believe you when you say crazy [ __ ] like
that
so at this point Mary who's the daughter
and Wesley who's the son they kind of
like compare notes and they're just like
man I've seen some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
she's like yeah I saw some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] too they're like maybe we should
tell Mom it's like look we've already
told Mom and she doesn't like believe us
so [ __ ] that [ __ ] now
um the kid like the eight-year-old he's
like we probably need to get the [ __ ]
out of this house right away because
this is probably really bad but Mary she
said she was really really into the
house like she really loved it in spite
of all the creepy [ __ ] that was going on
there but she said that she was afraid
that something bad was gonna happen to
Wesley but as the narrator points out
the ghosts aren't after Wesley they're
her instead you know what I mean because
you know how Anthony called us that's
that's what the narrator's name on a
haunting is in case you didn't know he's
[ __ ] iconic that boys
so one morning this was actually like a
pretty good scene
one morning like a few months after they
moved into this house Mary wakes up and
she finds out that she has fallen asleep
on the living room couch which you know
that happens
now she keeps hearing like a banging
sound like the same sound that's like oh
it's the ghost guy with the cane or
whatever and so the old band is like
apparently like standing behind the
thing and he's like yelling at her to
get up like why would the ghost care I
don't know but she thinks it's just a
dream at first like she thinks that she
sees him and he's making all this noise
but then like he starts whacking at her
legs with the cane right so right so she
thinks she's dreaming and she kind of
like rolls over to go back to sleep and
but she's like screaming and I was like
stop it stop it stop it and then like
apparently she says that out loud
because then her parents like rush in or
like what the [ __ ] what's going on like
because they were up getting ready to go
to work or whatever and she's like
um you know uh nothing I was just like
dreaming but she said when she woke up
she saw the ghost guy standing right
next to her mom
but the parents apparently don't see him
she's like he was right there like
standing right next to him
um so her mom's just like whatever I
just gotta go to work now her dad's like
okay I'm gonna go make you some
breakfast but then like looks at the
backs of her legs and there's like
bruises she said it was like bruises all
over the backs because you know the guy
had been like hitting her in the legs of
the cane or whatever
so he's like what will where did that
come from and she's basically oh I don't
know he's like what do you mean you
don't know I don't know I don't know
where it came from because like you know
she didn't want to tell him because she
thought he wouldn't believe her
obviously but yeah so the ghost is like
beating the [ __ ] out of her so that's
not cool
so at this point uh the dad is like okay
well obviously there's something really
weird going on in this place so um let's
all like have a little family meeting or
whatever so they all kind of get
together and compare notes about what's
been going on
so Barry and Wesley the two kids they
tell their parents everything and then
plot twist it turns out that their mom
Carol has also been experiencing creepy
[ __ ] she said like for a while she says
oh yeah well I've been also sensing
presences in the house and hearing angry
voices in the hallway and I was like and
all this time you've been like making
your kids believe that they were crazy
or that like you didn't believe them and
you were experiencing that [ __ ] too
that's like not cool but whatever
um I guess she was scared and that's why
she was pretending but still that's
that's still not cool now the dad uh
whose name is Jesse in case I didn't
mention that he has actually not
experienced anything because mainly
because he seems like he's at work all
the time so he's not home a lot but he
still thinks that something weird is
going on and obviously his whole entire
family is really uh upset about [ __ ] so
he's like well I don't really know what
to do so it's 1983. so let's go to the
church for help because that's what you
do like in the movies or whatever
so Carol and Mary they go to the local
Minister later that day but they both
said yeah this [ __ ] was like no
help essentially because they're like he
was really skeptical he was very not
supportive and he really didn't really
seem to give that much of a [ __ ] about
their story like didn't believe them so
he's basically like yeah well uh you
know just read some [ __ ] out of the
Bible especially like the Jesus he bits
and it'll all be fine whatever get out
of here get out of my office I have I
have Priestly [ __ ] to do evidently I
don't know I'm making that up
so um later on in the house Jesse the
dad he's like okay well we'll do that so
he gets the Bible
and he starts reading out of it with all
the Jesus he bits just like the priest
said to do but he's only been reading
for a couple of minutes when something
apparently like burned his hands like it
seemed like I don't know it made like a
kind of a burning noise like on the
reenactment and then like snatches the
Bible out his hands and it sends it
flying all the way across the room and
into the next room and they said these
are big rooms too so it went all the way
out that room and like into the Next
Room went into two rooms it went into
two rooms like she just picked up the
bottom was like shoo [ __ ] that Bible it
was just kind of like that so uh at this
point Wesley the eight-year-old he's
like holy [ __ ] this thing must be like
super super powerful it can throw you
know a Bible across two rooms
so not knowing what else to do Jesse
then calls his own sister whose name is
also Mary which is very confusing so I
feel like the rest of the movie The or
the rest of the episode they just called
her aunt Mary because the daughter's
name is also Mary so you know I guess
that's who she's named after
so Aunt Mary uh you know she kind of
like claims to be like an empath or a
psychic or whatever so she kind of comes
over and uh she evidently immediately
senses that something is the matter with
the house and she wants to go to the
attic because that's where she kind of
feels pulled toward or whatever
so she goes in there and she's like oh
my God this [ __ ] [ __ ] is so evil it's
that kind of thing and then as somebody
mentioned earlier on she pulls back the
rug and guess what's under there you
guys a pentagram yeah this is like the
there are so many haunting episodes
where they pull back a rug and find a
pentagram well and I kind of feel like
in the show here's what I think happened
in the reenactment
they showed the rug was just like an
area rug right and she pulls up the rug
and it's like oh my God a pentagram and
I was like whoa
if that area rug wasn't there before
then obviously when you moved into the
house you would have noticed that there
was a pentagram like a red pentagram
painted on the floor right but I think
what happened in real life if this
really happened which I doubt but I
think that the rug was like a you know
like wall-to-wall Carpeting and it's
like well we don't want to film it where
somebody has to pull up wall-to-wall
carpeting for Christ's sake and like
finding a [ __ ] pentagram under there
so it's like because an area rug like
you know you would
pull that up you would not get but yeah
so I so I get it but yeah so they roll
up the thing they're like oh my God a
pentagram it's evil so you know
apparently nobody noticed this before
so Aunt Mary says oh my God I feel
really bad energy uh we have to get out
of here but then she starts like choking
or gasping for air or something like
that
so she believes she has some kind of
vision or something
um that there's some coven that was here
and they had done some rituals like baby
sacrifice like they showed earlier and
had summoned a demon who was The
Reptilian apparently and that The
Reptilian demon had in turn trapped The
Creep Show old guy's spirit in the house
also you got that yeah okay so it's like
a complicated
it's a complicated ghost system that
they have going here
um she also thinks I don't know why we
laughed so hard at this but we did but
she also thinks the demon is trying to
possess Mary and would probably they did
use this word probably make her kill her
whole family yeah we were tripping
during this or Set Fire to the house
with all of them in it and I was just
like and you just
where'd you get this yeah I mean that
seems a little extreme like right out
the gate well this deep there's a demon
in here and maybe they're trying to like
possess you or something oh and probably
you would kill your whole family yeah
somebody's read The Amityville Horror is
what I think yeah but yeah um going a
little far that's what I mean and the
grown-up Mary was just kind of yeah I
would have probably killed my whole
family or set the house I'm like yeah
would you all right
that's never been recorded yesterday I
mean that seems a little that's a little
out there he's a possessed person just
rolls around talks a bunch of [ __ ] they
gotta hold him down every now and then
maybe they flow RSP oh yeah [ __ ] Uh
current spontaneous psychokinesis and
[ __ ] yeah masturbate with the crucifix
yeah then you know how they do but yeah
just just I don't know I just thought
that was funny though it's like oh the
demon might possess you and they just
immediately jump to and you'll kill your
whole family and I was just kind of like
God damn it all right yeah so Aunt Mary
because she thinks that you know the
little Mary is gonna kill her whole
family
um you guys need to get the [ __ ] out of
this house like right away and so
apparently Jesse and Carol the parents
they're just like okay I can't do so
they just like start immediately packing
up like they listen we're gonna get out
of here which is not something that
usually happens in these cases they're
like oh we can't move they're just like
yeah we're getting the [ __ ] out of here
but they said Mary though she suddenly
felt very she said she felt very calm
and like unworried like she wasn't
afraid anymore like she didn't want to
leave the house but she didn't she
couldn't like explain why she didn't
want to leave so she basically begged
her parents to let them stay there but
they were just kind of like yeah no
that's not happening you're gonna kill
us all so they basically just like
herded her out of the house because come
on we're going
um now Mary wonders she you know now
that she's grown up and she's on the
show being interviewed
she said she kind of wondered if the
house was making her feel that love for
the place like to keep her from leaving
and to like get her into that place
where it was like seducing her
essentially like the demon I guess
that's what she was speculating about
um because she said when they were
leaving she had the feeling like she
didn't care if any of them made it out
alive
and that maybe the demon in the house
had like sucked out her will to live and
it like made her
be obsessed with the house or care more
about the house than she did about her
family maybe you know what I mean that's
what she speculated about that later
so for a few weeks after they move out
because like I said they moved down they
were like [ __ ] that place because like I
said they were just renting it from the
um company that the guy worked for
so they split up for a few weeks to kind
of live with different relatives until
they could find another place to move
into two years later in 1985 the house
got torn down I'm not really sure why
um
I don't you know it seems like why would
they tear it down because it seemed like
from what they said it seemed like it
was in okay condition
so I don't really know if something bad
happened to those teachers I couldn't
really find anything about it
uh years later Mary and her aunt whose
name is also Mary and Wesley who became
a Paranormal Investigator later on uh he
was actually the director of Branson
paranormal which I'm assuming is in
Branson Missouri uh or at least was
until a couple years ago I think uh they
researched The house's history and
discovered that there had been rumors
that a coven met there I'm like well
that doesn't mean that there was a cub
in there that just meant that people
were talking about it coming being there
and also that there was a man with a
cane who was killed in the house I don't
know if he was murdered or what the [ __ ]
the deal was but they said that in the
thing so I was like well that seems a
little wishy-washy but okay uh Mary said
at the end that she still loved that
house in spite of all the [ __ ] that
happened there and that if she won the
lottery today she would build a house
just like it
even though like all that scary [ __ ]
happened there now when I did like some
out there wasn't a lot of outside info
about this but as I said the son who was
eight during these events
uh whose name is Wesley Fox
he became a Paranormal Investigator
later which happens a lot uh with some
of these now he wrote a book about this
case which is called House of Echoes
colon nightmare in the attic and that
was published in 2018.
he also wrote one called Deliver Us from
Evil colon a family's true haunting that
came out in 2015 and that was about
different family called the cupid family
who were also on another episode of
Haunting that was called Child's Play
which maybe we should do that one next
because I'm kind of interested and
actually I think that book is available
for free on Kindle unlimited so maybe I
could actually read that book and see
what was going on with that because I
checked it out and I kind of skimmed
through it but I was just kind of like
well this isn't about that case so I was
like I'll read this later
um and from just a cursory read and
maybe we'll get into this in a second uh
the book is super super christiany Okay
so
I kind of feel like that happens a lot
on these shows you get like these super
super christiany
because it's kind of a Trope in
Christian literature
to be like I grew up in a house that was
that had a demon in it and I vanquished
it or we ran away from it or whatever
and then they write a book about it
later on like after they become like I
feel like that's kind of a thing and
especially with people that turn up on
the show so I'm just saying that kind of
happened I'm not saying like [ __ ] didn't
happen I'm just saying that happens a
lot that's their inter well you know
what I mean something might happen and
so they're going to go to religion
because that's that's what that's what
your average culture is going to be like
um
now you might go to parapsychology also
depending on what part of the country
you're from so it makes sense that they
go to religion
yeah because they see something
invisible
so it's paranormal anything paranormal
spiritual you know that's uh it's it's
you know and they're and in electricity
seeing a spark would have been confused
with seeing something paranormal back in
the Roman area oh my God yeah you see a
spark yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that was that
was an angel or it was it was not well
no they wouldn't have said Angel back
then they would have said that was a
Titan
Yeah well yeah or some kind of demon
yeah
I noticed too I went to Wesley Fox's
Facebook page
and apparently he had a massive stroke
in June of 2022 he's the guy who wrote
this yeah yeah well he was the sun the
sun and he's grown up on this episode
and I haven't seen like he hasn't posted
anything since then like he said I had a
massive stroke but I'm okay or whatever
but it's like I don't think he's posted
anything since then and he had a link to
his website like on his page but I went
to it and it was somebody else's blog
like somebody that played piano or
something okay so I don't know if the
dude is still around anymore I'm just
saying you know I I don't I don't know
how that worked out but that was pretty
much the only stuff that I found like
outside about this kind of case like I
said if we do
maybe we should do child's play next
week we'll do Child's Play here because
then I can read Because I checked this
book out like on my Kindle unlimited the
guy this because apparently this dude
investigated that case which also turned
up on I think that was also season seven
okay so I think that makes sense so
maybe we'll do that one next and I can
read that book and get like some more
info about it so you hungry yeah I guess
I'm gonna start getting ready for this
meal all right I gotta get the damn
pork tenderloin ready gotta get the pork
tenderloin that's what he's making down
there yeah yeah that's what Tammy said
usually food knocks them off course yeah
it usually does yeah but not always I
mean anything anything can do it really
because we have like 80d you know but uh
but yeah so thank you everybody for
dropping by today like I said we will be
back again tomorrow talking about Todd
Browning's freaks which we are going to
be watching later on because that was
the one that tied with Godfather 3. uh
in the patreon poll and if you're not a
patron then you can go there and you can
vote on what movies we talk about so
that's like pretty neat so yeah so we're
going to talk about freaks tomorrow
thank you everybody for coming by thank
you for super chats and we will see you
guys again tomorrow good night